hey this is presh talarker a teacher
writes six words on the board
cat dog has Max dim and tag
the teacher hands a piece of paper to
Albert another piece of paper to Bernard
and another piece of paper to Cheryl
the teacher announces that each paper
contains a different letter from one of
the words on the board
the teacher asks aloud Albert do you
know the word
Albert replies yes he does know the word
the teacher then asks aloud Bernard do
you know the word
Bernard after a moment of thinking
replies yes he also knows the word
the teacher then asked if Cheryl knows
the word and Cheryl after a moment of
thinking also replies yes she also knows
the word
Albert Bernard and Cheryl always Ace
their logic exams
what is the secret word that their
three-letter spell
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we're going to analyze the letters in
each of the words in relation to the
responses that Albert Bernard and Cheryl
give
the teacher first asked if Albert knows
the word and he responds that he does
know the word
this means that Albert's letter can
uniquely identify a word
in other words the frequency of the
letter that he got is exactly one
for example consider if Albert had
gotten the letter c
the letter c only appears in the word
cat
so if Albert had gotten the letter c he
would be able to figure out that the
word is cat
in contrast suppose Albert had gotten
the letter A
while the letter A appears in multiple
words so there would have been no way
for Albert to figure out which word was
the word that they got
since Albert replied he was able to
identify the word that means he did not
get the letter A
so we need to find out which letters
appear exactly once in this list of word
we can go through all of the words and
we can figure out which of these letters
uniquely appear one time in this list
these are the letters c o
H or s
and the letter i
notice in the word tag the letters T A
and G all appear multiple times in this
list
so since Albert replied that he could
identify the word that means he didn't
have any of these letters the word
cannot be tagged
the teacher then asks Bernard if he
knows the word
Bernard after a moment of thinking also
replies yes so Bernard has heard
Albert's answer and wants to continue
the logic
so from this list of words and the
letters that are remaining
Bernard would be able to uniquely
identify which word they all had
so we go through this list
it could be the letter t
it could be the letter G
it could be the letter H if Albert had
gotten the letter s
also it could have been the letter s if
Albert had gotten the letter H
these are the possible choices the other
letters appear more than once in this
list of remaining letters that Bernard
could have gotten
what this means is that the word could
not be Max or dim
so we can eliminate those words
now Cheryl who has heard all of these is
then asked if she knows the word
she looks at her letter and thinks about
what Albert and Bernard had said and
also says yes I can figure out what the
word is
so continuing the logic one of the
remaining letters has to uniquely
identify the word
well there are only two letters left
there's a letter a and there's a letter
d
the only unique letter left is the
letter D because the letter A appears in
both the words cat and has
so Cheryl must have gotten the letter d
and it could not have been the words cat
or has
the secret word is dog
Albert would have gotten the letter O
Bernard would have gotten the letter G
and Cheryl would have gotten the letter
d
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and Game Theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google Plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at pressure Walker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description